[Music]
one important turning point in ursula k
le guin's fourth earth sea novel tahanu
is when ged the former arc mage going
not only by his name sparrowhawk but
also just as hawk reappears and we
should remind ourselves why is this so
centrally important well in
early on in the novel in the fourth
chapter ged is dropped off completely
drained of power near death by the great
dragon colessing tennar takes him in and
with the help of anti-moss
nurses him back to health he is emptied
of power
filled with fear
and you could say shame and humiliation
as he'll talk about a little bit later
and can't
face the young king who has sent envoys
out
looking for him on on gant
and so he flees he doesn't just head
south he flees to the south to herd
goats at first he was going to go north
and tenner says that's a bad idea you
know cutting hay you're an old man this
would be rough work at least become a
shepherd or something auntie moss sends
him on his way with some victuals some
some bread and some some cheese and meat
and he he's gone and so he's out of the
picture for a while except in the
memories
of tenor and the story proceeds tenner
ends up going back down to the farm and
she's there with pharaoh and all of the
other people involved with the farm and
then something happens
the
people who were involved with the
horrific abuse that pharaoh the young
burn child had endured handy and the two
other men come at night to try to break
in
to
take the child back and to punish both
her
and her adoptive mother tenor
and in in the struggle what we find is
um you know they're they're banging on
the shutters they say let us in we won't
hurt you
we just want to talk to you he just
wants to see his little girl you know
let us in and we won't hurt you and
tenner knows that they they will try to
hurt her then suddenly
there's a noise a howl and a sucking
gasp and a man yelled look out another
shouted here here then there was silence
light from the open doorway shot across
the black ice of puddles glittered on
the black branches of the oaks and on
fallen silver leaves and as her eyes
cleared she saw that something was
crawling towards her on the path a dark
mass or heap crawling towards her making
a high sobbing whale behind the light a
black shape ran and darted in long
blades shown
tenor
stop there she said raising the knife
tener it's me sparrowhawk hawk stay
there she said and she looks at him and
sees him with a long time pitchfork like
a wizard's staff
is that you she said he was kneeling now
by the black thing on the path i killed
him i think he said he looked up over
his shoulder and stood up there was no
sign or sound of the other men and as it
is god hasn't actually killed them he
stabbed him with a pitchfork this is one
of the the people who was going to do
harm to pharaoh and to to tenor um and
it glanced off of one of his ribs but
did him some considerable damage they
bring him in and eventually they will
turn him over to the witch ivy who will
bind him and heal him why because he's
going to hang he's going to hang or be
condemned to a galley
and so after these these three men are
attacking ged
is the hero who in some respects saves
the day right tenor is not completely
without resources she has a knife she's
trying to resist but she probably would
have been beaten and it turns out
that ged
ran across these men
he says
that that he heard them talking on the
way and he followed them down so he's
he's essentially
saved tenar and thero from a horrible
fate whatever these men were about to do
to them
get is going to stay the night with
tenar just in case the men come back
he's also you know almost frozen stiff
it's winter and they they catch up a bit
over time so that's an important thing
and you know there's no question of him
being able to stay
in part because
everybody recognizes that if he had not
been there catastrophe would have
happened and evil would have been done
now
after that their relationship is
going to
you could say change but we might
actually say instead
not change but
ripen coming to its fulfillment and we
need to remind ourselves who these
people are
ged was the
young wizard the mage who went into the
tombs of ottawa
seeking the lost half of the ring of
ereth akba when he had the other ring
tenar was the lone priestess the art the
high priestess of the tomb
the the nameless ones were her masters
and she and gad come to know each other
within the labyrinth where she has him
trapped and then
they make their escape together after
reforming the ring
she leaves ottowan leaving behind
her culture
her role
her power
everything about herself
coming with ged first to
present the ring at the isle of havnor
in the center of the world
and then coming back to gantt and
becoming the pupil of ged's former
teacher ojiyon until she decides to
to change that for becoming a farmer's
wife and raising children and managing a
farm
it's a long time for both of them
that they've been involved with each
other
ged recognizes even back in the tombs of
ottawa
the beauty and the resiliency and the
power and the capacity of tenor she's an
unusual person
she of course
recognizes him and she thinks to herself
several times earlier on in the story
why did we never
become involved and the answer is well
he's a mage he can't become involved
they're celibate why did we never even
consider that
now that's going to change emptied of
his power coming back as not quite a
triumphant hero but certainly the guy
who saved the day for the people that he
loves
ged and tenor can now
change their relationship it can become
romantic it can become
sexual
and she says to him
which bed shall i sleep and get the
child's or yours
he drew breath he spoke low
mine if you will
i will
the silence held him she could see the
effort he made to break from it
if you'll be patient with me he said
remember too this is an old man who has
never had sex
he has been a virgin this entire time
he's essentially you know like a as as
auntie moss has pointed out like a 15
year old boy
the boy who went off to rogue
then she says this is a very beautiful
passage
i've been patient with you for 25 years
she looked at him and began to laugh
come come on my dear better late than
never i'm only an old woman nothing is
wasted nothing has ever wasted you
taught me that
she stood up and he stood she put out
her hands and he took them they embraced
and their embrace became close
they held each other so fiercely so
dearly that they stopped knowing
anything but each other it did not
matter what bed they meant to slept to
sleep in they lay that night on the
hearthstones and there there's a
beautiful line she taught ged the
mystery that the wisest man could not
teach him and this is a great leguin
writing you know
something that so many people have known
love tenderness
having sex the intimacy that comes with
it something that people have
experienced throughout millennia and
it's it's not something that you know
costs you
anything other than commitment
in this case right and in so many other
cases and yet it's not something that
the the wise mages can actually teach
him anything about because they haven't
experienced it and don't think about it
for the most part
and this goes on there's a tenderness
between them that leguin is
very good at depicting
they woke again at dawn a faint silvery
light lay on the dark half leafless
branches of the oaks outside the window
tenor stretched out full length to feel
his warmth against her after a while he
murmured he was lying here hake right
under us ged made a small noise of
protest
now you're a man indeed she said stuck
another man full of holes first in lane
with a woman second that's the proper
order i suppose hush he murmured laying
his head on her shoulder don't
and then they they you know there's a
little bit more talking uh between them
then they lay in warmth and sweet
silence
and there's a lot of this going on
through
um the story
this vignette ends here
he raised himself up on one elbow so he
could look at her face his own face was
so open and vulnerable in its ease and
fulfillment and tenderness that she had
to reach up and touch his mouth there
where she had kissed it months ago which
led to his taking her into his arms
again and the conversation was not
continued in words so
they now have this possibility of
fulfillment of
as
people called it back in the day
conjugal love
there are some formalities to get
through
ged cannot just immediately become you
know her lover and have that ratified by
everybody just you know nodding their
heads instead she she's got to make a
case for why he's going to be
[Music]
a central part of the farm the chief of
the formalities was to tell clear brook
and the other tenants she'd replace the
old master with a hired hand she did so
promptly and bluntly they could not do
anything about it nor did it entail any
threat
to them a widow's tenure of her
husband's property was contingent on
there being no mail heir or claimant
um
going on a little bit further
to her relief they made no objections at
all hawk had won their approval with one
jab of a pitchfork besides it was only
good sense in a woman to want a man to
protect her if she took him into her bed
well the appetites of widows were
proverbial and after all she was a
foreigner the attitude of the villagers
was much the same a bit of whispering
and sniggering but little more it seemed
that being respectable was easier than
moss thought or perhaps that used goods
had little value so
ged antenna are now accepted as a couple
she is still holding the farm ultimately
her son will show up and they will in
fact leave the farm to him
but they're going to assume their roles
in relation to each other as life
partners these two very unusual people
they will have
rather intellectual but also practical
conversations they will face the future
together and they will move on into
their life with tenderness so gad really
does
come home
come back to tenar
in a way that
brings these matters to a successful
close he wards off the danger that has
been threatening them ultimately of
course they're going to fall into
another danger from which they will both
need to be saved
by
theroux
who by the way ged takes on as his own
daughter
as he takes on this new relationship
with tenor
so this is the
fulfillment of ged in a way that kind of
echoes the ending of a wizard of
earthsea except now it's not him by
himself it's ged
coming home to tenar
and to pharaoh and beginning a new life
together
you